[Music]
I was very much struck by how the
translation of the biblical writings
jump started the development of literacy
across the entire world illiteracy was
the norm the pastor's home was the first
school and every morning it would begin
with singing the Christian faith is a
singing religion probably 80 percent of
Scripps memorization today exists only
because of what is sung this is amazing
here we have a Gutenberg Bible printed
on the Press of Johann gubern science
and religion are opposing forces in the
world but historically that has not been
the case now the book is available to
everyone from Shakespeare to modern
education and medicine and science to to
civilization itself it is the most
influential book in all history and
hopefully people can walk away with at
least a sense of that
around 1900 almost everyone worried
about the fact that you could see cities
becoming more and more congested you had
uh horse carriages and they left an
enormous amount of manure so there were
lots of people who were really worried
about the fact that by you know by
extrapolation by 1920 1930 uh all of New
York all of London would be covered by
feet and feet horsemenure how are you
going to solve that and Along Came the
automobile the again the point here is
not to say that a technology that we
then innovate a hundred and twenty years
ago is the right one for today
eventually that will go you know the way
of the dinosaur we'll find other ways
but we should not be kidding ourselves
and believing that just wishing it
wasn't so makes it go away the way you
do this is through technology my concern
is that if you get people adjudicating
the what would you call it the
comparative validity of need you turn
the whole world over to people who say
well you don't really need that well
exactly who are you telling here that
they don't get to have what they need
because you don't mean that for yourself
you're not going to go live in a damn
Hut in the middle of us of Africa and
burn done you're not proposing that
you're proposing that these damn poor
people in the third world country and
maybe in your own country and there's
too many of those blighters anyways that
they should just be bloody well
satisfied with the fact that they've got
what they have now and they shouldn't in
in any manner ever dream of having this
sort of wealth of opportunities and
security that we have in the West
[Music]
hello everyone watching and listening on
the on YouTube or Associated podcasts I
have the great privilege today of
speaking once again to Dr Bjorn lomberg
we've talked several times on my podcast
before it's always good to talk to them
uh Dr lomberg researches the smartest
ways to do good with his Think Tank the
Copenhagen consensus he's worked with
hundreds of the world's top economists
and seven Nobel laureates to find and
promote the most effective solutions to
the world's greatest challenges from
disease and hunger to climate and
education
for his work Lombard was named one of
Time magazine's hundred most influential
people of the world
he's a visiting fellow at Stanford
University's Hoover institution and a
frequent commentator in print and
broadcast media for Outlets including
the New York Times Wall Street Journal
the guardian CNN Fox and the BBC his
monthly column is published in many
languages by dozens of influential
newspapers across all continents he's
also a best-selling author whose books
include false alarm how climate change
Panic costs us trillions hurts the poor
and fails to fix the planet
the skeptical environmentalists cool it
how to spend 75 billion to make the
world a better place the Nobel laureates
Guide to the smartest targets for the
world and prioritizing development a
cost-benefit analysis of the un's
sustainable development goals
all right hello Mr lawnberg very nice to
have the opportunity to speak with you
again I thought I thought today we would
start our discussion by talking about
what young people are being told and I
want to lay out a few ideas for you and
we can delve into this and and and we'll
move on from there so I've just been
reading Alex Epstein's book uh fossil
future and in that book he details out
first of all his belief that in the
foreseeable future that not only should
we not only will we have to use fossil
fuels but we should use them and he
explains why I would say on
on ethical and practical grounds but he
also says something that struck me as
very interesting which is that
the
view that's being put forward to young
people of the role of human beings on
the planet in relationship to the
environment is essentially predicated on
an implicit religious metaphor and I
want to lay out the metaphor
and I want to lay out why I think his
claim that it's a religious metaphor is
technically correct
so
the story is something like this the the
planet is fragile and virginal and
continually pillaged the pillaging
forces are the patriarchy essentially
the social structure it's a masculine
metaphor the social structure is viewed
as a force that's nothing but uh
devouring and negative and so you have
nature you have culture Nature's all
positive culture is all negative then
you have the individual also part of the
story and the individual is basically
characterized as some combination of
Predator
uh and parasite
and so
the reason that's a religious story as
far as I can tell is this is complicated
but I'd like to be able to lay it out
when I wrote my book in 1999 called maps
of meaning it struck me that the basic
cognitive and perceptual categories
where something like chaos
order and the process that mediates
between them I looked at a lot of
mythological work a lot of religion
religious writing across multiple
cultures and tried to
look at the correspondence between that
certain neuropsychological models that
were being built including models of
hemispheric processing so our
hemispheres are set up in some real
sense so that the right hemisphere
processes novelty and chaos and
possibility and the left hemisphere
imposes order
and the fact that the hemispheres have
this structure indicates because they're
adapted to the natural world let's say
indicates that the most fundamental way
of perceiving the world is something
like a place of possibility and chaos
and potential on the one hand and a
place of habitable order and culture and
predictability on the other so you have
those two domains and then Consciousness
looks like it's the process that
mediates between the two and and Epstein
now I learned in 1999 that these domains
chaos order and the process
we're always represented metaphorically
or symbolically it's like an a Priory
Axiom of cognitive
uh function and perception itself the
chaotic domain potential and so forth
tends to be represented with female
symbols feminine symbols and the orderly
domain tends to be represented with
masculine symbols and so you can see how
this plays out in the modern world
because you have Mother Nature who's
virginal and fragile being raped by the
catastrophic patriarchy and you can see
those metaphors lurking underneath right
there's the positive female the negative
male on the cultural front and then you
have to lay the individual on top of
that and the individual in that story
positive feminine negative masculine is
also represented negatively
now
that's a very compelling story because
it does cover all the domains of
existence and there is a
beautiful and plentiful and positive
element of untrammeled nature let's say
and there is a tyrannical and predatory
aspect of culture and the individual can
be a destructive parasitical and
predatory Force but that's only half the
story and that's the problem
and so
the point I'm trying to make is that we
can't structure our perceptions without
using something like an a priori
category system and the a Priory
category system whatever your a priority
category system is your religion it
functions in exactly the same way and we
have a religion now that's focused on
nature worship the derogation of culture
and the damnation of the individual and
that's the story that's being told to
young people right the planet's fragile
culture is nothing but a destroying
force and individual effort is to be
construed as predatory see in the
patriarchal sense and parasitic on
parasitic in relationship to the natural
world
so
so I'm wondering what you think about
that uh yeah no I I think it's I know
it's a lot of it's a great metaphor uh
so so again uh if if we go along with
this and and if we all have religion I
would tend to say that my religion is
data uh you know there's a famous
statisticians that say if you uh without
data you're just another guy with an
opinion right we have a lot of knowledge
about the world and the reality is that
much of this is built on you know
stories and metaphors and things that
we've heard and it's probably not very
conducive to understanding what the
world is actually like and I totally
agree with you that everybody not really
just young people but especially perhaps
young people are told this is the end of
times you know this idea of should you
really have children yeah put them into
this world this terrible world uh the
world is going to end in you know
whatever the number is right now but you
know eight years or 12 years or whatever
the feeling is that this is sort of end
of times
and that's very much as you point out a
sense of we have this beautiful world
that we somehow this natural world that
we've somehow despoiled and made
terrible in so many different ways and I
would argue that certainly if you look
back in time this very clearly is a very
modern way of thinking about the world
uh you know two three hundred years ago
we were terrified of nature because we
really worried about you know the Wolves
Out There we were terrified about nature
in the sense that it would kill us in
all kinds of ways just you know think
about one of the things I'll talk about
a little later uh smallpox uh a disease
that we've eradicated uh in 1978 uh but
even in the 20th century it killed about
300 million people so you know it killed
what a couple of you know somewhere up
to five million people every year this
is a terrible disease it was not the
only disease that you were that you were
struck with this killed you know royalty
and everybody else
nature used to be terrible what has
happened is that we have actually found
a way to live such that we can now say
we like nature we love nature we want to
set aside lots of nature remember uh you
know most of European nations can cut
down most of their Forest uh to build
navies to you know fight each other but
the fundamental point is you get
reforestation
when you're rich when you're well off
when you can actually deal with the
issues and so again that tells you
something that I think is incredibly
important if we're actually going to
have a good conversation it is that you
need to understand
overall things are moving in the right
direction and that we're much better off
you know with just one statistic if you
look at the number of people that die
from climate related disasters so these
are the disasters that we hear about all
the time you know floods droughts storms
wildfires extreme temperatures those
kinds of things we have pretty good data
for that we certainly have good data for
the last 100 years how many people die
every year well it turns out that in the
1920s about half a million people died
each year from those disasters that's a
terrible outcome of the world how many
people die today if you ask most young
people if you ask most people in the
world they'll probably think that number
has gone up and up and it's just worse
and worse nothing could be further from
truth
last year it's the last full year that
we have 2021 less than 7 000 people die
we've seen a decline of more than 99
why it's got nothing to do with climate
it's not because climate has gotten
better or indeed really worse we can't
really tell in most of these impacts
there's a few of them we can't but
mostly we can't what has changed is our
ability to handle it that's why we don't
die from smallpox that's why we can
afford to actually make sure we have
forests that's why most rich nations are
reforesting and that's why fewer and
fewer people are dying from these
disasters so I think we need to tell
that alternative story if you will that
yes you hear all these terrible things
and it doesn't mean that there are no
problems there's still lots of people
that are uh you know terribly troubled
from floods there's still lots of people
that are terribly troubled by droughts
and all these other things there's still
a lot of info infectious disease from
both tuberculosis malare the world is
not fine but the world is much better
and that's important because that put us
in a very different frame of mind it
means we are not in
looking at the world being dispoil and
hence we need to make some sacrificial
offerings to you know please this this
uh deity that we're worried about it's
instead to say look we're actually
dealing with this in the right direction
we're actually making things better but
we can do even more that's a very
different message and of course one
that's much more optimistic and I I
would hope well it's also more balanced
okay so so you started talking about the
relationship you know your your
concentration on data and so I wanted to
I wanted to delve into that a little bit
so
there there's data of course and data
would be something like a representation
of the patterns in the world not not
merely the subjective patterns not
merely the psychological patterns but
the patterns in the well let's say the
objective world of the patterns that
exist in
somehow the transcend mere subjectivity
and so those are patterns that we're
going to test our presumptions against
but part of the reason I wanted to delve
into the underlying metaphorical
substructures because a lot of your work
and the work of the more non-naive
optimists that I've encountered in the
last 10 years has this counter narrative
element that structures it I mean
because you're a Priory axioms they're
the reverse of the environmentalist
axioms in some sense and in this way is
is what I mean is that
you started your description by pointing
out that we shouldn't be lulled into
thinking that nature is only benevolent
it's only been a very short period of
time in historically speaking that any
of us at all anywhere on the planet had
the luxury of ever assuming that nature
was a benevolent Force for more than a
few seconds right and so because nature
is conspiring in all of its benevolence
to destroy us as rapidly as it possibly
can all the time as well with cold and
heat and floods and disease and and acts
of God and volcanoes and and earthquakes
etc etc and so you have to be extremely
naive if you don't also see nature as a
threatening Force
so now you shouldn't see it as only a
threatening Force because we're also
dependent on it all right so and that so
you you flesh out the malevolent nature
side of the story but then you also say
well look everyone who's listening don't
be so pessimistic about our culture our
Western culture let's say but the global
culture even more broadly because in
many ways we've been moving in the right
direction things are a hell of a lot
better by almost every metric you can
imagine than they were 100 years ago
they're better by most metrics than they
were 50 or 20 years ago and not just a
little bit better A lot better so and
then so then you can flesh out the
positive side of the culture and then on
the individual side you can say well you
know there are people who are predatory
and there are people who are parasitical
and and everyone is subject to
Temptation and and failure to hit the
mark let's say but by and large people
are striving in the right direction and
you can view human beings as a positive
force even though there's some
ambivalence about that and so that flesh
is out the story you know you can also
think about it as Rousseau versus Hobbes
and strangely enough you come down more
on the side of the harbesians even
though I don't think that's your
temperamental proclivity because for
Rousseau right
the nature was all positive we were
turned into negative creatures because
we were perverted by our socialization
and human beings well for Rousseau human
beings were innately good assuming that
they weren't warped and Twisted by
culture but Hobbes had the alternative
Viewpoint Hobbs said well the Nate the
state of nature is chaos and War
and we need a strong socializing force
in order to integrate and organize us so
that peace can obtain and I've thought
for a long time that the a comprehensive
worldview melds Russo and Hobbes it's
the same
comprehensive religious idea in some
sense is you need a representation of
nature that's positive and negative you
need a representation of culture that's
positive and negative and a
representation of the individual that's
positive and negative and we've we've
offered a
crippled religious view to young people
it's also got this apocalyptic end right
this apocalyptic undertone which is not
only is nature virginal and fragile and
culture rapacious and predate predatory
and the individual corrupt but this is a
bloody emergency and the apocalypse is
upon us like if it isn't tomorrow it's
10 years from now all of that's
religious Force I would say operating at
the metaphorical and mythological level
and a lot of what you've been doing
and I want to go I want to get at the
foundations of this a lot of what you've
been doing is saying well look let's
just hold on on the apocalyptic Vision
side it isn't obvious that the bloody
catastrophe is upon us now in any manner
that
would make
in cautious emergency action anything
other than destructive there's no reason
to assume that as a social Force we're
only predatory and parasitical and we
could we could give ourselves some
credit for striving in the right
direction and also being able to master
this because one of the things that I
really liked about your work and about
many of the people who are working in
the optimistic front this is mostly
economists do this is the idea that
well we don't have an apocalyptic
Challenge on our hands but we have some
challenges but we're the sort of
creatures that can actually Master those
challenges if we don't panic and do
something too stupid yeah no and look
that's exactly the right point I I
actually think I love your uh your uh
Hops and uh Russo i i in some ways uh
you're probably right that I would argue
of course the world originally was like
hops not Russo but what we've actually
managed with a hundred you know three or
four hundred years of hard work is that
we have turned the world into something
that's much closer to Russo I'm not sure
I'm there I'm going to go down in
history with this philosophy lesson uh
but yeah the fundamental point is what
we achieve is by making the world safer
for us by actually achieving to make
sure that people don't die from smallpox
and that they don't die from all these
other things that we can actually
produce a lot of the things that we need
for our world in a much more uh uh
sustainable way remember you know if you
look at the uh at the history of for
instance fire of the last 10 000 years
typically whenever uh you know uh humans
come around they just burn the whole
stuff because it's in their way right
you know if you're Indian uh we have
lots of evidence to show that Indians
just burned large tracts of of of land
because it brings out the animals you
know it makes them defenseless and you
can kill them and you eat them it makes
a lot of sense but that's really
destroying nature what we're doing now
of course is to a very large extent that
we grow very efficient food so that in
rich countries at least in countries
that have sufficient resources to
actually care about other things than
just surviving they set aside more and
more nature that's why you know just in
Denmark where I am right now
um you know we we used to have about a
third of the country covered in in
Forest then we caught about all of it
down so we're down to about two percent
now we're back up to 14 why because
we're rich we actually like like and we
plant for us so that we have places to
take our kids out and watch it and so
again the point here is there is it's
not just optimism it's actually realism
to recognize that you're only going to
fix the problem by looking at the data
finding out what are the challenges fix
many of these challenges and realizing
you can't fix everything or at least not
everything at once so you fix the most
important challenges that takes the
least resources to get the most impact
so you know fundamentally uh and and
again this is what the economists love
to say the ones that have the biggest
bang for the buck but in reality it's
much more about making sure that if you
can only do some things sometimes you do
the smartest stuff first and that's
what's brought us to here and that's why
we should stop saying it's the end of
the world but still recognize that there
are plenty of of troubles around and and
again also just let's remember you know
we're sitting in two developed countries
where we're very well off where we're
not worried about you know neither
smallpox because we've eradicated that
but we're not worried about tuberculosis
either we're not worried about not
having enough food we're not worried
malaria all these yes all these
different things that most people in
this world so you know by far far over
four billions or probably more like six
six and a half billion uh of the eight
billion we are on the planet are worried
about every day and and and that's why
I'm also really frustrated with this way
that we're very often so focused on
saying you know for instance on climate
change which is a real problem we're
saying it's the only problem and then we
forget about all these other things
where we could help much more make sure
that people are saved much better and
that they could also then eventually get
to a point where they would want to you
know preserve nature and think about
other things and just simply uh making
sure they survive the night
okay so we talked about some of the
reasons that this new quasi-religious
view of the world and our place and it
might have Arisen your your point was
that well because of technological
progress we've been able to begin to
view nature as a much more benevolent
Force than we ever had the luxury to
before but there's some other yeah
there's some other social pressures
let's say that are pushing this
narrative forward that I think are worth
delving into you mentioned one when we
just had a bit of a preliminary
conversation is that
there's a huge competition for people's
attention online and that competition
has intensified dramatically
um in the last 20 years because there
are so many voices clamoring for
everyone's attention all the time and
one of the advantages to an apocalyptic
vision is that it is attention grabbing
and so we have so any narrative that
tilts towards the apocalyptic
is likely to get magnified in online
communication because uh things are good
and slowly getting better isn't much of
a headline and it right and there's no
there's nothing novel about it okay so
that's one that's another possible
contributing fact can I just another
give you one one so please do uh uh so
uh the world our world and data It's a
Wonderful website uh and and they point
out I love the statistic uh you know we
have no sense of how many people we've
lifted out of poverty so over the last
25 years since yeah and the order almost
a billion people so every year for the
last 25 years we could have had a
headline in every paper in the world
everywhere around
telling us last yesterday a hundred and
thirty eight thousand people were lifted
out of poverty
how come you never I hear that that is
that's just an astoundingly amazing
thing and and yes there are still many
problems yes there's so many poor people
but the fact is we you know 200 years
ago we used to be almost all
extremely poor yeah there was a few
royalty on that and then you know it was
90 95 of all of us had what would you
know typically known as a dollar a day
but it's really to 2.15 now but the
fundamental point is we were incredibly
poor
now we have less than 10 percent that
are extremely poor that's still a
problem we should still help them and
there's a lot of ways we could do that
but that is one of those many stories
that you don't hear because yeah it
doesn't generate clicks
we'll be right back with Bjorn lomberg
in just a moment but first there's no
better way to study scripture and
develop a dedicated prayer life than
with hallow hallow is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the U.S and the
number one Catholic app in the world
it's filled with studies meditations and
Reflections including the number one
Christian podcast the Bible in a year
download Hollow today and try their
Advent prey 25 challenge a 25-day
journey through Bible stories from both
the Old and New Testament leading up to
the birth of Jesus these meditations are
led by cast members from the largest
Christian streaming Series in history
The Chosen Advent pray 25 will help grow
your understanding of mankind and
develop a disciplined prayer habit
during a season when our discipline is
put to the test
download Halo for three months
completely free at hollow.com shorten
that's hallow.com Jordan give yourself
the gift of Peace calm and discipline
this Christmas go to hallow.com Jordan
today
[Music]
yeah well part of it part of it and it's
a deep psychological problem too is that
we are structured psychologically so
that the negative has more impact than
the positive does and so and that's a
very difficult bias to work against when
you're in a situation where you might be
making the case that the positive should
be what's predominating it's like well
fair enough but that isn't exactly how
we're wired and I suppose that's why
because we can be a hundred percent dead
but only so happy and so it right it's
conservative in some sense and I don't
mean politically to be a little more
hyper alert to the negative than to the
positive but that's a tough thing to
fight against when the negative can grab
attention especially when it's blown up
to apocalyptic proportions okay so
there's a couple of other things I
wanted to delve into there too so
there's this psychologist Jean Piaget
and Piaget is very interested in
ethical development and cognitive
development
he developed a stage theory of of human
cognitive and moral development across
time and the last stage in his sequence
of cognitive slash ethical
Transformations was the Messianic stage
and not everyone hits that but more
philosophically sophisticated young
people pass through something
approximating a mess ionic stage and it
occurs somewhere between the ages of 16
and 21 which by the way is the right
stage of life to bring young men into
the military if you're going to do it
effectively like there's there's a whole
uh
radical process of neuronal pruning that
takes place between age 16 and 21 that's
analogous to what happens between the
ages of two and four it's almost as if
at that point you die into your adult
configuration
right so because you're pared down to
what is only going to work for your
environment okay so now
one of the psychological consequences of
that is that when when young people are
in this stage of development and they're
looking for how to separate themselves
from their parents and to maybe even
move beyond the narrow confines of their
immediate friendship group they're
trying to catalyze their identity with a
broader social mission
and
in
archaic societies that
step would be catalyzed by something
like an initiation ritual where the old
personality is symbolically destroyed
put to death that's that accounts for
some of the torturous elements of the
initiation ceremonies and then the new
man because the initiation ceremonies
tend to be more intense for boys
the new man is brought into being as a
as a cultural entity and then he's
aligned with the mission and purpose
let's say of the tribal unit it's
something like that well
right now I think the radical leftists
on the environmental side have been very
good at capitalizing on those urges
because what they offer to young people
is this
but it's pathological in some real sense
because it's a shortcut to mess ionic
to mess ionic moral virtue so the idea
would be well there is an apocalypse we
need to save the virginal Planet so
there's a bit of a Saint George thing
going on there to protect the Virgin
let's say and the way to do this is to
become something approximating an
activist who's dead set against the evil
patriarchy and the predatory and
parasitical individual and you can
understand why that's attractive because
it does offer young people a Grand
Vision they're now Protectors of the
planet they're participating in
something that's beyond themselves
but the problem with it is is that it's
it's an invitation to a very one-side
story and it's got this terribly
destructive anti-human element and so
so well I'm curious about what you think
about that I I think it's a very good
metaphor for you know how how the world
uh and in many ways have come to work I
I think you're you're absolutely right
it's a very sort of uh stimulating and
very uh easy message to fall into the
world is terrible but here is how we can
help and and the story very easily
become I'm going to help by cutting tons
of CO2 now again I bring my data points
yes yeah and and so I think there's two
parts of it I mean first of all I think
we should recognize it's wonderful
that young people and really everyone
wants to do good we should encourage
that we should that's wonderful and yeah
again it's part of the fact that we're
now well off that we can stop worrying
where's our next meal coming from and
then we can start thinking about so how
are we going to help the world but the
reality is that when we're being told
this it's the end of the world and hence
this is this the only thing that matters
we're very likely to make very poor
decisions I mean if it was true you know
if there was a meteor hurtling towards
Earth the only thing that mattered I was
gonna you know sort of Wipe Out the
whole world the only thing that matters
was to get this you know the space
shuttle the uh whatever the Starship or
whatever up there and deflect it that's
what we should be focused on but that's
not the right metaphor for climate
climate change it's a problem right and
it's a problem that we in many ways as
we can as we saw with that statistic I
told you on before yeah the fact that
we've seen dramatically declining levels
of people dying from climate related
disasters because we can actually adapt
to much of this and because we can
predict it we can make sure that the
people become more safe from these
things it's not the end of the world it
is a problem and saying this is the only
problem makes us very likely to make
really poor decisions because we only we
focus on this can't forget all the other
let me just one other thing so so I
think there's two point points to one is
that thinking it's the end of the world
and thinking this is the only problem
make you forget all the other problems
but also when you look at then what are
the solutions that are typically offered
they're terribly inefficient so they'll
typically involve something along the
lines of saying you know I'm gonna forgo
driving my car which will at best have
virtually no impact it's not that you
know please do it if you if if it makes
you feel good especially if it works
into your plans but it's not how you
solve the world and you know people will
talk about going vegetarian again great
thing I'm I'm vegetarian yeah but but
yeah it's not going to save the world
you need to get a sense of proportion
most of the things that people talk
about are small fractions of what it'll
actually take and what they're really
suggesting and what everybody's now
talking about is this Net Zero idea that
we need to cut all carbon emissions from
all economy economies uh by 2050 this
would be enormously costly and also so
terribly terribly fatal for many
countries especially the poorer
countries who basically keep alive by
having lots and lots of access to fossil
fuels one way of of just seeing that is
right now
half the world's population survive on
nitrogen that comes from fertilizer that
comes from natural gas we have no way of
knowing how we could possibly get enough
nitrogen to feed most of the world if we
went to Net Zero we saw a small example
of that was a very badly performed
example in Sri Lanka but still it's
worthwhile to point out you cannot
actually feed most of the people on the
planet if you want to go organic and go
NetZero right now and that tells you a
story because as as uh Norman Bullard
love to point out one of the Nobel
alerts that actually helped saved you
know a billion people or so he said I
look around the world and I don't see
four billion people willing to give up
their lives right so there's no 4
billion volunteers to say all right I'm
not going to be here we need to be
realistic about this and say the current
Solutions often very counterproductive
so stop believing it's the only problem
and stop arcing for bad Solutions okay
so so so let's talk a little bit about
that too from a motivational perspective
so we have this appeal to the Messianic
urge of young people but now here's how
the appeal gets warped because it is the
case that each young person should take
their place as a responsible productive
and generous member of the broader
social order but that's really difficult
that's genuine moral effort and that
would require growing the hell up being
willing to make sacrifices including the
future in your deliberation so you're
not impulsively hedonistic serving other
people starting a family starting a
business like all these things that you
have to do in the micro world that
require real effort well here's the
shortcut
that's being dangled in front of young
people it's like forget about all that
all that activity that difficult
painstaking conscientious local activity
that's all just part of the predatory
parasitical patriarchy so you can just
dispense with all of that instead you
can put yourself forward as an ally of
virginal nature and instantly as an ad
as an anti-apocalyptic advocate of that
sort you're elevated to the highest
possible moral stature which is
something like well it's something like
a mess ionic figure I'm saving the
planet it's like well I don't think you
are I don't think you're doing any of
the work necessary to save the planet I
mean one of the things I really liked
about your work when I came across it
and that's probably it's got to be 15
years ago or more now was that
you had done the detailed data-driven
work that was necessary to differentiate
the landscape of problems so first of
all you'd admit to the complexity of the
problems that were in front of us you
weren't falling prey to the idea that
there was only one problem there was one
solution and you were the person merely
by advocating for that solution who was
now God emperor of the world there was
none of that in your work and and I
think part of the reason it's had a hard
time getting traction to some degree is
that you're insisting to people that
they actually pay some attention to the
complexity of the of the of of the
challenges that confront us right and
the problem with that is that that runs
contrary to this
narcissistically attractive
metanarrative which is no no you can
just oppose the patriarchy and
everything that goes along with it all
that responsibility which maybe you
don't want to shoulder anyway and you
can instantly become morally Superior by
being a climate change activist and some
of that's attractive to the Messianic
Drive in young people but also some of
that's attractive to just straight
bloody what would you say
hypersimplified narcissism because
people one of the dark motivations of
people is to obtain unearned moral
virtue because we need reputation and if
you can put yourself that's why we
worship allies now you know if you can
put yourself forward as an ally of the
noble cause then all of a sudden you
have as much moral stature as anybody
could hope to gain but you haven't done
any of the real work and the real work
is the devil's in the details and the
data in relationship to the real work
so so one more thing to add on top of
that so there's this this enticement
that we're offering to young people it's
like
well here's a world view
we can identify the villains the
villains are a culture and the predatory
individual you can be an ally now you
have overblown moral virtue merely
because you're on the right side and
then you don't have to think through any
of this because you've already got the
story right even though it's a one pixel
story so that's a very bad moral trap
but then there's something darker going
on too you know in Epstein's book fossil
future he cites some of these the more
radical environmentalist types who say
things like I think it was McKibben he
quoted who said something like
as far as I'm concerned
the Vista of an unspoiled River so any
natural environment that's completely
Untouched by human beings
is so valuable that it would that one
person or a billion isn't worth that
it's something very close to that and so
there's a there's a malevolent
anti-humanism that's at the bottom of
this too which is also it's part of this
metaphor it's part of the idea that
intrinsically human beings are something
like a cancer on the face of the planet
or a virus or a biological Force that's
gone wrong a malthusian nightmare and
that only that which is completely
unsullied by human beings Untouched by
human hands is intrinsically valuable
and you can put that forward as a moral
claim and say that you're on the side of
nature but the flip side of that is like
yeah like if there's too many people on
the planet their mate which of them do
you think should go and exactly how are
you going to bring that about and so
that's the dark side of this of this
like apocalyptic environmentalist
utopian narrative is that human beings
are categorized as evil in and of
themselves and all human activity as
evil and
you know one of the things that we've
discussed is that not only is that a
pathological Viewpoint and extremely
dangerous but interestingly enough it's
probably also counterproductive
from the hypothetical perspective of the
environmentalist utopians because if the
goal is to produce a Greener more
biodiverse planet let's say
then it seems to me there's something we
can discuss that the evidence suggests
very strongly that if you make people
richer we can talk about what that means
if you make people richer in in a in a
benevolent manner or at least you get
the hell out of their way then they
start caring about the environment in a
distributed Manner and you get a
positive relationship between the
remediation of absolute poverty and
environmental awareness so not only does
this narrative not solve the climate
problem and destroy the economy it
actually makes I think it makes the
climate problem a lot worse and we're
seeing that play out in Europe right now
Shopify is the all-in-one Commerce
platform trusted by millions of
entrepreneurs to create their online
store and so much more Shopify makes it
simple to sell to anyone from anywhere
whether you're selling succulents or
stilettos start selling with Shopify and
join the platform simplifying Commerce
for millions of businesses worldwide
with Shopify you'll customize your
online store to your brand discover new
customers and build the relationships
that will keep them coming back Shopify
covers all the sales channels to
successfully grow your business from an
in-person POS system to an all-in-one
e-commerce platform even across social
media platforms like Tick Tock Facebook
and Instagram thanks to 24 7 support and
free on-demand business courses Shopify
is here to help you succeed every step
of the way it's how every minute new
sellers around the world make their
first sale with Shopify and you can too
sign up for a free trial at shopify.com
jbp go to shopify.com jbp to start
selling online today that shop fi.com
slash jbp
I I think there's there's a number of
things to unpack here so I I think
you're absolutely right that we have
very good evidence to saying if people
are better off they're much more likely
to be environmentally concerned
environment problems are poverty
problems that's really what that is you
know right poor yes you just cut down
forest in order to feed your kids you'll
basically litter around everything
because honestly you have other things
on your mind right now whereas once
you're well off and most of your future
is secure you can care a lot more about
the environment and I also think yes
you're absolutely right there's a lot of
people who seemingly get a lot of sort
of instant credit uh by just throwing
paintings or whatever uh you know
painting it whatever famous painting
they're in and and a museum with uh or
or just you know get some sort of you
know glue themselves to highways or
whatever that's not how you solve this
problem because it is very very
complicated and and as you also point
out if you actually want to make part be
part of the solution help bring the
world onwards it's actually going to
take a lot of painstaking work and I
think you you nailed it on on why why
are my Solutions much harder to sell
well fundamentally because it's more
boring it is not as flashy and exciting
as being able to you know uh get on a
tick tock video and show your virtue but
it's actually about a lot of hard work I
I mentioned uh Norman Bullock uh uh he's
he got the Nobel Peace Prize in 1970. he
was the originator there's a lot of
other people along with him for the
Green Revolution that basically worked
through the 60s and 70s uh and and most
of uh uh most people today probably
don't even remember it but if you go
back and read what people were worried
about we were incredibly worried about
the fact that most Nations just would
not have enough food uh and and and so
you know there is literally people
considering maybe we should do triage
and say Well India is just a gone goner
you know they'll just have to sort of
die out uh and and what Norman Bullock
said was we actually have the technology
to make much more food on every hectare
every acre of land we do that by making
genetic modifications so he just did it
with you know normal uh uh genetics he
simply constructed together with lots
and lots of other researchers
constructed seeds of both rice and wheat
that were shorter and that meant they
were shorter and so they could put more
energy into their uh kernels and that
meant there are many more kernels much
less straw and we got much more food
that is you know in a very short uh uh
hand that's basically what fed the world
that's what brought India from being a
basket case to now being the world's
leading race exporter it doesn't mean
they're not problems in the media it
doesn't mean that we've fixed everything
but what that tells you is this is the
way you actually walk towards a solution
so a lot of environmentalists a lot of
you know very very smart thinkers Back
Then basically said lots and lots of
people are going to die literally yeah
right millions of people are going to
die and I'm okay with that because you
know it had to happen yeah whereas the
right way is to sit down and actually
use science and spend you know your
entire life
working and making these rice grains
more effective it's not nearly as sexy
and of course I'm only telling the big
story because he got the Nobel Prize you
know there were lots and lots of other
researchers whom I don't even know and
none of us really remember anymore but
those are the people that actually made
it work and so I'm often struck as you
also pointed out I'm often struck when
people say there are too many people on
the planet because when you yeah when
you drill into it it means you know just
enough of me but too many of you it's
never yeah you're actually going to have
you or your family leave but you think
someone else should go now I get the
idea of saying that maybe in some sort
of very detached way we would like to
see a world that had fewer people I I
think that's probably wrong but you can
have that argument but if you actually
look at it in you know in the
philosophical implications of that is
that you're telling lots and lots of
people to Die the reality should be I
think and that's what our history shows
us is when you have rich and wealthy
countries you can actually get both you
both get fewer fewer kids because yeah
once once you grow up once you get rich
enough kids actually start to be really
expensive so you have few of them and
that's one of the reasons why we no
longer see this population explosion as
people talked about in most of the
ritual actually were likely to see that
you know spread over the whole world in
the next 40 years or so so we are over
most of the problem and what we have
managed to do is we can now grow food
much more effectively and we should be
moving towards growing it even more
effective more effectively so that we
can have all the people well fed on less
and less land so there's more space for
nature we're doing that in the ritual we
can also do that in the poor
the thing that's interesting here or one
of the things that's interesting you
talked about Norman borlag and about the
sexiness of of say your vision and the
thing is when I started to delve into
the research on the economy and
environment front I actually found the
work that you were doing so to speak
highly sexy because I thought oh my God
here's a better story
we could make everybody in the planet
rich and I want to go into what Rich
means and at the same time
make the planet much more sustainable on
the biological front we could do both of
those why isn't that just way better
than the malthusian zero-sum game Let's
delve into those issues a little bit so
so we're we're offering young people a
cheap way out of their privilege induced
guilt so now they've had they have this
rusoian landscape set in front of them
they're pretty secure they're they're
pretty comfortable they're not going to
die of malaria or smallpox they have
enough to eat they have the educational
opportunity but now they're scrounging
around trying to figure out what to do
with their life because they need to
justify their miserable existences to
themselves they need something
meaningful and so the radicals come
along and say well just be an ally of
the virginal planet and that is simple
so it has that appeal
but it's also simple in an underhanded
way because it it isn't the message look
why don't you be like Norman borluck
and develop something like a noble
Vision which is well maybe we don't have
to starve four billion people to death
maybe we can feed them okay what do
people eat oh they eat food
yeah so how about if we make food more
efficient we make agriculture more
efficient let's see if we can feed all
those people and that's a pretty hard
problem so how about I devote my whole
life to this
and then you might say to young people
well that's a hell of a price to pay to
devote your whole life to something but
we could be saying forthrightly well
don't you want an identity
I don't you want to devote your life to
the solution of some genuinely difficult
problem I mean that's where you're going
to find meaning I mean how meaningful
has your work been to you very
meaningful and and I think uh so I I
just wanted to slightly flippantly but
not only flippantly say I'm very very
pleased and gratified that you thought
this was this was uh very exciting uh I
I think it's also a little bit because
you're a nerd uh so you know it is a
more nerdy solution yeah and and it is
less immediately satisfying but I think
that's exactly the point we need to get
out we we need to tell people this will
ultimately be a much much more rewarding
understanding look we should also have
people that work on climate because
again climate is a real problem but
you're not going to solve it by throwing
paint at something you're not going to
solve it by telling people you can't you
shouldn't you should freeze you should
not have a nice life the way you're
going to solve this of course this by
being the guy that comes up with the
technology that actually delivers clean
energy or cleaner energy at much lower
cost this is how we've solved pretty
much all problems we haven't solved them
by wishful thinking or telling people
I'm sorry could you not do stuff that
you like to do that never works what
does work is you come along with a
better solution you know this is a
slightly trite uh uh metaphor but back
in the
1860s uh the world was basically fishing
up all whale or whales why because
whales have this wonderful opportunity
of whale oil turns out the whale oil
just burns much much cleaner and much
brighter than any other oil remember
that was pretty much the only lighting
that you had back in the 1860s so pretty
much all Western European and North
American Rich homes were were lit up
with Whaler and and so everyone just
went out and you know to the ends of the
world to catch whales you could not have
stopped the slaughter of Wales by
telling everyone I'm sorry could you
could you Dim your lights a little bit
could you go back and have that
light that you didn't like that's not
gonna work what did work was ironically
that we found oil in Pennsylvania right
that we actually found ground oil the
oil that we just used today mineral oil
and you could substitute that for whale
oil turned out it was much cheaper it
burnt better and it was much easier to
get hold of and so we pretty much
stopped hunting whales after that there
are still some because you know they
also give meat but the fundamental point
is technology solves this problem not
good intentions
right well so that means that we can
thank the fossil fuel industry for
saving the whales and you can you know
if if you think about well we can thank
the fossil fuel industry for a lot of
things if you think about uh in around
1900 almost everyone worried about the
fact that you could see cities becoming
more and more congested you had uh horse
carriages and they left an enormous
amount of manure so there are lots of
people who are really worried about the
fact that by you know by extrapolation
by 1920 1930 uh all of New York all of
London would be covered by feet and feet
of horse manure how are you going to
solve that and Along Came the automobile
the again the point here is not to say
that a technology that we then innovate
120 years ago is the right one for today
eventually that will go you know the way
of the dinosaur we'll find other ways
but we should not be kidding ourselves
and believing that just wishing it
wasn't so makes it go away the way you
do this is through technology well
especially okay so let's talk about
wealth a bit because in the west it's
easy for people like I I saw yesterday I
think it was Extinction Rebellion or one
of these damn groups put out this
message saying that well you know people
should just stop Flying because flying
produces water vapor and carbon dioxide
and you know really we don't need to fly
and so I I'm reading that I'm thinking
well because there's Marxism of a
terrible uh type lurking under death
it's like well who the hell determines
what we need exactly I mean needs are
first of all needs aren't self-evident
really what you need to do is you need
to breathe
you need to drink water and you need to
eat after that what constitutes a need
gets pretty damn dubious and my concern
is that if you get people adjudicating
the what would you call it the
comparative validity of need you turn
the whole world over to people who say
well you don't really need that and you
don't really need shelter you don't
really need well you don't need you can
have bugs you don't really need food you
can you can eat a minimal protein Source
well you don't really need children
because they're they're kind of hard on
the planet anyways you certainly don't
need pets because they add to the carbon
dioxide load you don't need your
fireplace you don't need a gas stove you
don't need a heater
and so and then what you have is this
insistence that the way the planetary
salvation is to tell other people what
they don't get to have and what's
interesting about that too and this is
the hypocritical element and I certainly
see this at the elite Davis Global level
it's like well exactly who are you
telling here that they don't get to have
what they need because you don't mean
that for yourself you're not going to go
live in a damn Hut in the middle of us
of Africa and burn down you're not
proposing that you're proposing that
these damn poor people in the third
world country and maybe in your own
country and there's too many of those
blighters anyways that they should just
be bloody well satisfied with the fact
that they've got what they have now and
they shouldn't in in any manner ever
dream of having this sort of wealth of
opportunities and security that we have
in the west then we could talk about
wealth because people in the west are
guilty about wealth well we have all
these things we don't need it's like
well yeah that's actually the definition
of wealth you got a choice of
toothbrushes maybe you don't need it but
it's not a bad side effect but we should
get down to Brass tax here people when
we're talking about wealth
for the typical person here's what we're
talking about
your house isn't too cold or too hot so
you have Heating and maybe you have air
conditioning that'd be kind of nice you
have running water
you have good sanitation so you have a
toilet and you have clean water
you have a plentiful supply of high
quality food that you don't have to
spend all your time scrounging around to
deliver and it's reliably sourced and
your children have the opportunity to
live to live healthily and to be
educated that's like 90 percent of
wealth and so when we're talking about
wealth that we want to provide the rest
of the world we're not talking about
1920s spats wearing capitalist
depredations champagne hooker and
cocaine we're talking about
the basics of life right temperature
regulation provision of water provision
of food health and opportunity for
children and we still haven't provided
that to everyone in the world and we
could that's one of the things that's so
optimistic about your work not only
could we do that we should do it and we
could and should do it in a way that
would benefit the long-term
sustainability of the planet
no and and Lord again uh you you rightly
point out that people will want to
manipulate your choices and and not only
does that have a dubious and uh sort of
moral uh impact but it's also you know
just from an economist point of view if
you tell people you can't fly it's not
like they're going to say oh I was
actually gonna I was planning on
spending five percent of my income on
flights so I'm just gonna burn these
money I'm just gonna spend it on all
their stuff which also produce carbon
emissions and so you know we've no sense
of saying the only real way and I've
some respect sort of intellectual
respect for these people who are
actually saying the only way to solve
global warming is by making everyone
poor what's called degrowth first we
make the rich world uh poor and then
once the poor world has gotten slightly
richer we also say stop to them uh at
least it's intellectually honest it's
also terribly terrible it's not a human
and it's not going to happen there's no
constituency no politician would ever
get voted into office or if if he or she
actually delivered on it would get
re-elected on on that sort of platform
and what that tells you is this is this
is just simply you know again wishful
thinking and I keep getting back to
saying if you're actually serious about
problems are you gonna you know are you
going to suggest something that'll
actually work are you just going to
suggest something that makes you feel
good or you know that you know have no
chance on on Earth to get uh carried
through again there is an argument and I
think there's a legitimate argument for
putting a carbon tax on things that's a
simple way that we make regulation that
says there's a global bad here we tax it
and then you put that Global bat into
your considerations but that's how you
solve it efficiently and of course the
reality of that is that in any realistic
formulation of this people will fly
slightly less and that's no good for
many of these moral uh Crusaders because
they want to completely get rid of it
it's not going to happen what needs to
happen
truly want to solve this problem again
is to get Innovation you know we already
know how to for instance decarbonize
most of the electricity system it's just
through nuclear we know that's worked
for 50 years the reason why we're not
doing it and the reason why I'm a little
skeptical about it is that it's too
costly right now we can have a whole
conversation about why that's the case
but there's a lot of innovation going on
about fourth generation nuclear that
could become much cheaper we just saw
the Breakthrough maybe uh Fusion as well
but but the point is that there's lots
of Technologies those are the ones that
we're going to focus on because again
you're not going to tell people you
can't have your whale you have to dim
your light what you can say is oh here's
a better alternative oh it also happens
to be cheaper and it doesn't kill whales
Black Rifle coffee company is helping
you knock out your holiday shopping with
a ton of awesome new products this year
shop the best Brewing gear thermosis
mugs and apparel designed for folks who
love country and coffee Black Rifle
sources the most exotic roast from
around the globe all coffee is roasted
here in the U.S by veteran-led teams of
coffee experts stuff your Christmas
stockings with the latest roasts from
America's coffee for 10 off with the
code Jordan better yet sign your Secret
Santa up for a coffee Club subscription
imagine the joy of a pre-scheduled
coffee delivery your favorite roast when
you need the most it's the gift that
keeps on giving Black Rifle coffee
company is veteran founded and operated
they take pride in serving coffee and
culture to people who love America every
purchase you make with Black Rifle helps
support veteran and first responder
causes go to blackriflecoffee.com and
use promo code Jordan for 10 off coffee
Coffee Gear apparel and when you sign up
for a new coffee Club subscription
that's black riflecoffee.com with promo
code Jordan for 10 off Black Rifle
coffee supporting veterans and America's
coffee
[Music]
no one do you so the degrowth model is
predicated on the idea that well let's
lay out the ideas that really there
there are too many people on the planet
and the people who are there now
especially the rich ones are consuming
far too many resources per capita and so
the only way forward to a sustainable
planet is through D growth okay so let's
take that apart first of all who's going
to impose that D growth like can you
imagine the totalitarian state that
would have to be built
in order for every single one of your
purchase to be monitored which is really
what the plan is in some real sense I
mean that's just a terrible nightmarish
vision of petty tyranny everywhere where
every single move you make is analyzed
in terms of its overall planetary
consequence and only calculated by
people who do not have your best
interests in mind by the way but but
worse than that is that there isn't any
evidence whatsoever that if you use this
strategy of degrowth and you make people
poor that you're going to get anything
approximating the beneficial
the fact that you propose I mean let's
look at how this is already playing out
so what has Germany managed with an
approximate degrowth strategy I mean so
part of the deep growth as well we
certainly don't need fossil fuels or new
or nuclear on the energy front Okay so
from what I've been able to gather now
energy is about five times more
expensive per unit cost in Germany than
it is in the United States a huge number
of industrial Endeavors are fleeing
Germany for U.S which isn't so bad or
China which is really not good because
it's too expensive even to do such
things as build batteries for electric
cars in Germany now but also you might
say well that's all worth it because now
we have all these Renewables and that
the place is much cleaner and if we have
to pay a price in terms of loss of
industrial productivity C'est La Vie but
I read the other day too and I hope this
is accurate that Germany has fallen to
something underneath the 100th position
in the world in terms of
emissions per unit of energy produced
because as we've moved foolishly and
precipitously towards unreliable
renewals especially on the wind and
solar front the Germans have had to
especially because they killed their
nuclear plants they've had to turn back
to coal
and so now they're burning way more coal
than they used to for five times the
electricity price and unreliable power
to boot and so this degrowth philosophy
which which violates the presuppositions
of economic motivation let's say on a
psychological and economic front is not
only going to demolish
the industrial structure make the poor
much poorer and more desperate but it's
going to bring about
worsening of the conditions for
environmental sustainability and very
very rapidly now we're also seeing in in
Europe and you can comment on this a bit
is that because we're now in an energy
crisis
foolish energy crisis that people are
starting to Deforest Europe and they're
starting to burn peat in Ireland again
because they have to heat their damn
homes so even by the standards of the
environmentalists themselves
perverse though those standards may be
the degrowth philosophy is completely
unsustainable politically and
psychologically because you're just not
going to tell people you know you can
let Grandma freeze in the dark I think
you're absolutely that it's not going to
happen uh you know people are just not
going to allow that and they won't
accept that sort of uh of uh tyrannius
you're talking about you would need much
much more than anyone would be willing
to to offer up just to give you one
sense of it uh for the average American
uh some estimates indicate that going
Net Zero would actually cost you in the
order of 12
000 per person per year by 2050. yeah
that's just impossible to imagine than
anyone uh would would ever accept
and also I think we need to separate
there there has been this tendency in
almost all conversation to totally model
climate and environment now environment
is a lot of other thing things and it's
for instance air pollution and all these
other things that are fairly you know
local uh to you so D growth would
actually solve climate change because we
would stop producing it wouldn't solve
a lot of the other environmental
problems because now we would start you
know burning everything else and we
would be terribly poor and you know life
would be horrible in so many other ways
I I think fundamentally we just need to
get back to realizing that when you're
saying and you know these protesters
will glue themselves to the roads and
say we don't want you to use any fossil
fuels but of course when they come back
in their lives they're crucially
dependent mostly on lots and lots of
energy produced by fossil fuels and they
would probably most of them not be
willing to give that up and if they're
not even willing to do that of course
they're not going to get anyone else to
do that just by gluing themselves in on
on highways sorry sorry what they're
going to do is they if they could come
up with a new innovation that was
cleaner than anything else if they
instead of you know gluing themselves to
the road would actually take up the
university go and and you know figure
out and it need not be as solution to
climate change but one of those
Solutions but one that was actually
effective then of course they would have
done really good in the world and so
again that I think that's the sort of
purpose of our whole conversation to say
you know stop believing this is the end
of the world because it's not but also
stop believing that the solution to the
end of the world is to glue yourself or
to just be gloomy or tell everyone we
should just stop with everything the
solution is
Smart Technologies that the solution to
the end of the world
is not to become a frightened Tyrant
that says oh my God this guy is falling
I need all the power now I need to make
these centralized decisions these
centralized decisions are going to
affect every single element of your life
and your children's life assuming you
get to have children at all and that's
going to bring us towards a more
benevolent Planet it's like none of
that's true there's not an apocalypse
you don't get to be afraid and Tyrant we
don't need centralized top-down control
of absolutely everything we do and even
if we did have all of that what we would
get wouldn't be the positive outcome
that everyone who's on that side is
touting what we get is the same kind of
centralized planning disasters that
we've seen play out time and time again
over the last hundred years all over the
world this is every single way you cut
this this is a bad set of solutions now
I want to still manage a little bit so
you know the the the idea that there are
too many people on the planet is
actually predicated on you might say you
might say data which is one of the weird
things about data is that if you put if
you take a petri dish that's full of uh
a nutritive medium and you put a mold on
it the mold will grow until it eats all
the available nutrients and then it will
all die
and so that's a kind of limits to growth
model but the world in that model is a
encapsulated petri dish and the
biological agents are Mindless
single-celled organisms so you might say
well that's not a great metaphor for
human beings because first of all human
beings aren't mold or viruses or cancers
we're we're a very strange breed of
creature because we can
we can think and we can react and we can
modify the environment and we can modify
ourselves and so it isn't obvious at all
people say follow the science the
science is malthusian we're all you know
microorganisms in the petri dish or rats
in a colony we're going to overpopulate
till we devour everything it's like I
don't think so if you first of all why
would you use single-celled organisms as
the Cardinal metaphor for human
for for human populations it's a
Preposterous biological metaphor and one
of the things the economists have
pointed out as opposed to the biologists
who tend to be more malenthusian
repeatedly is
look
you can you can create your linear
models of what's going to happen if
but what you're failing to take into
account is the the proclivity of people
to revolutionarily transform the way
they interact with the world and to
continually figure out how to do more
with less and there's no indication
whatsoever that we've run to the end of
that process quite the contrary we'd
seem to be getting faster at it all the
time and there's no reason to assume
that
the limits to growth petri dish model of
human catastrophe is the appropriate
biological metaphor that's not justified
by science and 99 of scientists don't
believe it and one of the things that's
so interesting you know this perfectly
well is that economists and biologists
have been betting against each other
really formally since the mid 60s and
the biologists like uh what's his name
at Stanford Paul Ehrlich who's been
screeching since the mid 60s about the
fact that we're malthusian organisms
doomed to Extinction he's been wrong in
every single one of his predictions and
publicly and massively and I would say
even murderously wrong in some
fundamental sense so he predicted that
there would be way too many people on
the planet by the year 2000 that was
seriously wrong he predicted that all of
the prices of our Commodities were going
to spike through the roof as everything
became more and more scarce as there
became more and more of us that was 100
percent wrong he had a famous bet with
Julian Simon and Simon collected I think
just after the turn of the Millennia
because Simon The Economist claimed that
no no quite the contrary as there are
more people there'll be more Commodities
there'll be more resources and the
prices will fall he even offered Ehrlich
the opportunity to pick the basket of
Commodities they would bet on an early
Ehrlich got stopped and what we've seen
continually time and time again is the
economists have been right which is that
human there's no limit to human
Ingenuity and that also means that if we
got
Food Water Sanitation opportunity to the
billions of people that don't have it we
would produce a few more spectacular
hyper Geniuses like Elon Musk let's say
or Norman borlag and God only knows what
sort of efficiency they can produce for
us so the idea that we could convert
natural resources into human cognitive
ability that seems like a pretty damn
good trade from the perspective of
economic flourishing and environmental
sustainability yeah so just two points
in that I I think it's incredibly
important to remember that it's not just
the Elon musks and the uh Norman
Bullocks that make up the world also
because you know it is you you very
early on uh said that you've done all
this great work and thank you very much
uh but yeah this is the work of
literally many hundreds of the world's
top economists that I've helped sort of
Shepherd together uh but there are lots
and lots of people involved and likewise
with Norman Bullock I'm sure that's also
true with Elon Musk and and so the
fundamental point is this is about
getting everybody on board through this
and and that's also why I'm so excited
we have this conversation because I
think this is about telling you don't
need to be Elon Musk to be on this
positive side of History you need to
make sure that you're pitching into this
very long battle in order to make the
world better uh and again also sorry I'm
just being the nerd here right but of
course nobody's a hundred percent wrong
you know the I I get that this is a sort
of metaphorical hundred percent but it's
more the argument here is to recognize
that a lot of biologists and Julian
Simon actually wrote about that the guy
you mentioned that the uh the bet with
Paul early and he said it is very
curious how uh most of the people who
think the world is going to end are
typically natural scientists they're
typically biologists or biologists
inspired and I think that is because the
models that cover those and it's not
just mold but it's also you know Fox uh
uh uh what is it rapid populations that
they will they will sort of interact and
then there are too many Rapids and then
there's too many foxes and so on those
are all model
of individual
without foresight and it makes sense
that's how you know yes of nature is but
we're not that we actually not only know
how to think ahead of ourselves that's
of course why we're having this
conversation that's why we're worried
about things like climate change and
again uh you mentioned very early in the
program you know that there's sort of
evolutionary reasons why we tend to uh
to be uh worried about stuff uh I I
heard this one guy saying you know we're
the descendants of the guys who worried
about the saber-toothed tigers you know
the guys who said oh they'll be fine are
the ones who you know didn't get to pass
on their genes so in in that sense it
makes perfect sense and we should be
happy that there's a lot of people out
there pointing out this might be a
problem Oh my good this could actually
be a problem we just shouldn't believe
that all of those problems are then all
of the ends of the world because if our
evidence or they're all the same
problems yes if our evidence told us
anything sorry that is that overall we
have enormously succeeded I just want to
give you one of the data point uh you
know in 1900 the average life expectancy
on the planet Earth was 32.
a is like 74. we have more than doubled
our lifetime each each one of us has
twice amount of Life on this planet that
that's astounding
chili it hasn't stopped because of
technology and because medical
advancement but also because we get
better you know sanitation and
everything else we actually continuously
see life expectancies that go up it
hasn't done so in the US and we could
talk about that but oh globally it
absolutely does and it still does in the
sense of every year you live you add
about three months to your life
expectancy how amazing about a stunning
statistic yep that's true okay so so
let's so let's let's go back to the
biological metaphor here okay so we've
already established I hope for everyone
listening that we are not mold in a
patriot dish that's a bad metaphor so
now you said well maybe we're foxes and
rabbits
and there is this nature red in tooth
and Claw that's going to mod modulate
our population by necessity and that's
sort of the biological argument that
even though we're not mold let's say
we're going we're more like Foxes or
rabbits and we're going to multiply
until the predators take us out or
something like that but I would say
here's why biologically that's not true
so Alfred North Whitehead I believe it
was said the reason we think
is so that our ideas can die instead of
us
so here's the the human cognitive
transformation
so imagine that you go do something
stupid and you get killed
well that's not so good now you're dead
but your pattern even your DNA is no
longer around that's a dead end it's an
evolutionary dead end you did something
stupid and now you don't exist and
neither do your descendants
okay so that's how animals work
but that's not how human beings work
because we've taken this new leap I know
our leap is well let's make a
virtualized self let's make an let's
make a uh an avatar in imagination
let's play out a few different scenarios
of what might be let's allow the stupid
scenarios to die before we Implement
them and then let's do that broad scale
that's why we have free speech so what
you and I are doing in this conversation
to the degree that it's successful and
this is what everyone who's listening is
doing too is that we're undergoing a
sequence of micro deaths and micro
rejuvenations and so you'll offer an
idea
and then all criticize it or add to it
and kill some of it and shape it and
then you'll take that and you'll kill
some of it and shape it and we'll toss
it back and forth with the hopes that by
the time we finally implement it we
actually won't have to die
and so human beings have substituted the
ability to think abstractly which is
partly to die abstractly for the process
of real death and in principle if we are
capable of maintaining open dialogue and
engaging in critical thinking we can
make most of the death that would
otherwise be necessary to control our
populations virtual we don't actually
have to act it out we can act it out in
simulation and then we can only
implement the ideas that seem to be
productive and we're actually really
good at that the whole human Enterprise
is precisely that so that's another
reason why the biological model is just
not tenable we are not of the same kind
even as foxes and rabbits certainly not
of mold and certainly not of cancer or
viruses
and so the biologists who were thinking
seriously they have to take this into
account and I don't think they are
you know to paint with a broad brush
no and I I I I think I I think that is
why you have all these economists
telling us actually in many ways we have
moved on and we're much better at fixing
problems and I again I think it gives a
better way of thinking about problems
that you say yes it's great that there
are people out there pointing out
problems I'm happy that organizations
like Greenpeace are there because they
point out and nip at the heels of you
know corrupt officials or governments
that don't do their job and simply tell
us these are potential problems but it
shouldn't be taken as oh my God that
means we're all gonna die no it means
here is another of the many many
problems that have set us from all you
know time and Memorial and that we've
also fixed and typically fixed in a way
that actually left the world better not
worse off the environment is not
purchased at the expense of the economy
and the economy is not purchased at the
expense of the environment necessarily
they can work in harmony
and we know that well how do we know
that we know that because as you
accelerate people up the GDP production
curve so every individual is making more
money you get to a point where people as
we already pointed out start to take a
longer term vision and that Vision
includes environmental maintenance so
let's say we want a vision for the
planet on the environmental
sustainability side so let how do we do
that well why don't we produce as many
people as we possibly can who are as
concerned as they can be that they're
relatively local environment the one
they can actually control is as green
productive and sustainable as possible
we want billions of people working on
this not just a few
well how do we get billions of people
working on it well we help them with
cheap energy and the provision of
plentiful food we help them provide
security for their family and
opportunity for their children and then
we enable them to take a longer term
View and they'll automatically start
attending to the sorts of concerns that
are hypothetically that hypothetically
predominate among the environmentalists
and the data that that's going to happen
is very clear yeah so just uh are very
clear so just to take a step back the
economists typically call this uh the
inverse could snaps curve so basically
what you see with most environmental
problems as you get richer first
problems increase you know you get more
air pollution as you industrialize in
China or in India and then once you get
sufficiently rich that this is actually
meant now your kids are not dying you
have enough food they then you start to
worry and say I'd actually like to cough
less and so you get the other side of
this so there is a a sort of
intermediate disconnect so once you
start getting people out of poverty they
actually get more pollution now if you
lived in that situation you would
undoubtedly make the same decision you'd
say I'd like to have more food and more
opportunity for my kids and then I'll
cough a little bit that's remember what
we also did back in the 1800s when
pretty much all cities here in Europe
and the US were terribly terribly
polluted but we were getting richer and
richer so there is this disconnect for a
short time but it's very hard to imagine
that the right way is to say well then
let's not at all start down the route of
getting much better off and actually
living in a world yeah well we both like
and that where we'll actually be worried
about the environment in the long run
we'll be back in one moment first we
wanted to give you a sneak peek at
Jordan's new series Exodus
so the Hebrews created history as we
know it
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
and we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest
[Music]
Spirit to which we're beholden is
presented precisely as that spirit that
allies itself with the cause of Freedom
against tyranny
I want villains to get punished but do
you want the villains to learn before
they have to pay the ultimate price
that's such a Christian question
while it's not like the developing
countries are going to go along with
this noise they're just going to tell us
Colonials to go take a flying leap which
is exactly what they should do and
because basically what we're telling
them is well you know we got pretty rich
and we're pretty happy to fly in our
private jets to Davos and and think
about the globalist Utopia but uh we
don't think you guys should have any of
that and you know the faster you get at
being poorer the better and let's just
absolutely no reason no no likelihood at
all that places like India and China are
going to do anything but lift a middle
finger to us when we do that and rightly
so and so and then on the pollution
front we we should we should
differentiate that a little bit it is
true that as the world got more
industrialized and that will happen in
places like China and India that air
pollution increased for example
particulate production increased but it
increased it you could argue that it
decreased inside houses as it increased
outside houses and so even that wasn't a
clearer
like downside on the pollution front
because while your work has indicated
this quite clearly or at least you
brought it to people's attention in the
developing world because people burn
dung and wood very low low quality fuel
with high particular content many many
young people around the world are dying
every year and elderly people as well
because of indoor air pollution
we have no sense of this so you know
three and a half billion uh people in
households mostly in the very poor South
uh they basically as you say cook and
keep warm with dirty fuels like dung and
cardboard and the impact of that is
equivalent according to the World Health
Organization to if you look inside Huts
if you've ever been in one in Africa the
terribly polluted inside uh and it's
like smoking two packs of cigarettes
every day for three and a half billion
people it's not surprising this kills
millions of people every year and again
it's not to say you know if if anything
this just simply makes us realize that
there are a lot of different problems
and some of them you solve very simply
by getting people out of absolute
poverty not only did they stop dying
from uh not having enough food and
getting easily curable infectious
diseases but also they stop dying from
indoor air pollution one of the first
things they do is they get a stove that
actually runs in natural gas uh remember
that's why we're not you know afraid of
going into our kitchens in the rich
world and so it should be in the poor
world and we need to have that
conversation we need to understand and
that's of course why overall getting to
develop country status is is something
that almost everyone aspires to and
certainly something that's worth having
okay so let's let's uh let's talk about
some of the so people who are who are
listening we've we spend a lot of time
in the philosophical realm and in the
relatively low resolution realm trying
to lay out the underlying conceptual
landscape and to what would you say
delineate something like a metaphysics
of optimism that might be a good way of
thinking about it but but one of the
things that's admirable about your work
is that you also concentrate on the the
d The Devil in the details and so
we we wrote an op-ed recently that got a
fair bit of of distribution on a couple
of problems that we could solve
globally let's say we could address at a
relatively low cost billions of dollars
instead of trillions and so that's like
one thousandth the cost for people who
want to do the mathematics so what do
you see
what what could people think about in
terms of low-hanging fruit what are
things we could address in the next 10
years to speed the process of
improvement and to address both economic
and environmental issues simultaneously
yeah you know it's a it's a great
question and that's really what I've
been spending uh the last couple years
on and really a very large part of my
career uh is basically engaging people
and saying there are lots of problems
and and we should be honest about that
the world still has lots and lots of
problems some of them are very hard to
solve some of them are very easy to
solve if that's true why wouldn't we
want to solve the easy ones first some
of them are incredibly expensive to
solve some of them are very very cheap
to sell why wouldn't we solve the cheap
ones first so what we try to go for is
simply as you said the low-hanging fruit
saying of all the different problems in
the world where are some really smart
Solutions and it typically ends up being
such that you can't solve all of the
problem remember we rarely solve all of
any problem we don't you know you don't
you don't go to university to learn
everything you go to learn University to
learn enough uh you don't you know well
I could go on without metaphor I don't
think I will but the but the point here
is to say you need to find out when is
enough enough what are the really smart
things so take one thing that we that we
actually wrote about in the in the op-ed
um everyone needs education one of the
reasons why countries have gotten rich
is that people will have learned Reading
Writing communicating understanding and
becoming much more productive citizens
so if you look back in 1800 almost the
entire world accepts her very slight
tiny sliver of the aristocracy were
basically illiterate we are now in a
world where more than 90 are at least
technically literate we've moved an
enormous amount of way and that's why a
lot of rich countries are rich that's
why we're well off that's why we have
the human flourishing that we have so
this is incredibly important to
understand we believe that almost half
of the difference between being poor and
being rich is whether you have an
educated population now nobody disagrees
yes we should all have educated people
but the truth is it's really really hard
we know that in rich countries because
we have that conversation constantly how
do we make our schools better but it's
much much clearer in the rest of the
world so we look a lot on what's uh what
the World Bank calls the low income and
lower middle income countries so that's
about half the world population is 4
billion out of the 8 billion we're on
the planet so you could say it's a it's
the poor half of the world in that part
of the world when you do studies you you
probably heard about the Pisa studies
you know we try to find out how good our
people how good our students around the
world to do different things so there's
similar kind of studies done across
pretty much all of the world it turns
out and this is terrible so there's 650
million kids in school so kids and
adolescents in school and the lower uh 4
billion uh of of the world so in the low
and Low Middle income countries of these
kids
80 percent
cannot read and do math in any
reasonable way and let me just give you
an example of what that means it's not
you know rocket science it's for
instance you let them read a statement
like this Vijay has a red hat a blue
shirt and yellow socks what color is the
Hat
eighty percent of the kids can't answer
this when they're 10 years old uh
likewise a 10 year olds to a a math
question would be we have six pieces of
cheese
what is the way to divide this to two
people so each get the same amount and
again about eighty percent can't the
right answer is three by the way but
yeah this is really depressing and and
the truth is we don't know how to fix
this we know a lot of ways that don't
work so for instance in Indonesia in uh
2001 the parliament decided they spent
about ten percent of public expenditure
on education so a lot of money on
education but they decided we're going
to do more
so they decided we're going to put in
Constitution that we need to spend 20 on
education that's you know potentially a
great thing you really want to help the
country so what they did was they built
a lot of new schools they got many more
teachers that they went up from 2.7 to
3.8 million
teachers they now have one of the lowest
class sizes in the world they have great
teachers they have lots of teachers and
they're really well paid unfortunately
you couldn't tell the difference in the
outcome on students they were still just
as bad and of course what that tells you
is and so there's there's wonderful
study it was called double for nothing
uh you know we basically in Indonesia
paid twice as much and got nothing out
of it that's the worst kind of way to
try to help the world now a lot of
people will make these arguments we need
to pay teachers more it turns out that
if you pay teachers more they become
really really happy which is not
surprising but it doesn't actually
increase uh uh learning by students
likewise if you make class sizes smaller
it has virtually no impact what is the
main problem here the main problem is
it's really hard to teach a lot of kids
so you know say there's perhaps 60 kids
in a in a class in typical global South
to teach them they're all 12 year olds
but they're wildly different abilities
you know some of them are incredibly
bored because they know all the stuff
and they want to go on to the next class
many of them have no clue what's going
on no matter what the teacher tries to
do it's always going to be wrong for
most of the students this is why you
know a lot of people have then tried to
say are there ways to solve this and the
answer is yes these are the Norman
Bulldogs if you will of the world who've
come up in new and interesting and
Amazing Ideas I'll tell you about one of
them so this one is about getting
basically a t teaching Aid on a tablet
so it could be an iPad but it'll
probably be a cheaper you know knockoff
Android kind of thing and then it
teaches you at your level so what it
does is it starts asking some questions
and you you can pretty quickly find out
what what is actually your level and
then it'll teach you through that school
year so one hour a day this is partly
because then you can actually still have
most of the school running as it usually
do then it also means you can share the
iPad with or the tablet with many many
other students over the day one hour a
day
for a year the amazing thing is we now
know that you can triple the learning
you can actually make kids learn three
times as much as this as if they'd gone
to school three years now remember it's
a low quality school so it's not as
amazing as it sounds but it's still much
much better yeah but it's an improvement
well what it means Bjorn is that you
know you're now putting children for an
hour a day
into the only place that learning
actually takes place so we've known this
psychologists have known this for a
hundred years so this psychologist named
vygotsky Russian psychologist came up
with this notion called the zone of
proximal development and what he noted
was that parents spontane one of the
things he noticed was that his parents
spontaneously speak to their infants and
their toddlers at a level that slightly
exceeds their current
comprehension level
and they do this automatically and so
you can imagine that there's a horizon
of learning and the Horizon of learning
is the place that's optimally
challenging for you that's the only
place that's also by the way on the
border between Order and Chaos uh
technically speaking that's the only
place that learning ever takes place and
so if you have a classroom full of 12
year olds say 60 of them some of them
have an IQ of 70 which means no matter
how you how hard you try no matter how
much effort you expend you'll never get
them beyond the basics of rudimentary
literacy and some of them have IQs of
145 which means those are kids who could
learn to read at 12 to 1500 words a
minute and who'd be capable of operating
at the highest end of cognitive
development they're all in the same
class well obviously you can't pitch to
the middle of that because as you said
you'll make a shambles of it but the
data that you're laying out in terms of
the effectiveness of this technology is
an indication of the utility of finding
that zone of prox maximal development
that's what people talk about by the way
when they talk about the Zone being in
the zone and we can and I like the
particularity of your solution too
because you're saying well look we need
to educate people we need to educate
them because educated people generate
more of the wealth that provide security
and opportunity literacy is core to that
and say basic numeracy you can't even
operate a computer without that and then
we have some very efficient
technological strategies that are also
cost effective where we can Target and
solve that particular problem it's very
particularized and so and that's also a
lovely Vision it's like well why not
make education cheap and useful it's
incredibly simple and also remember
there are lots of other Solutions don't
first focus on those focus on these
incredibly effective ways so you know we
talk about and there's lots of of
different data that shows how do you
make sure these tablets don't get stolen
you so you need a place that you lock
them up for the night how do you treat
recharge them you need the solar panel
you need all that cost you also need
some people to operate right you but all
of this has actually been proven so one
of the things that we've helped do uh
and this is by no means just us uh is
now uh Malawi one of the poorest
countries in the world is actually uh
aiming at over the next four years to
spread this out to all of their schools
so that's more than you know 3 000
schools and they get this out to all one
to four year four graders fourth graders
that's an amazing achievement again this
is the kind of thing they'll make Malawi
richer because they'll become more
productive in the long run so we do the
whole for cost and benefit calculation
so this will have real costs yeah we're
talking about several billion dollars if
you're going to do this globally the
billion is a very low number when you're
thinking about how much we're spending
on some of these other problems is as
you mentioned there's not a trillion and
secondly it's going to dramatically
improve all of these countries to become
better so that they will both be better
off to have human flourishing but in the
long run also a better environment we
actually then try to say well so for
every dollar you spend how much good do
you end up doing turns out that you make
so much good that it's equivalent to
fifty four dollars of social good in the
long run so every dollar in fifty four
dollars out and this is based on which
is 54.
that's 54 more dollars that you could go
off and do some more good with too yes
so although you know
much of this is somewhat out in the
future because that's what it is all
about yeah of course but you know we we
have this reflexively anti-capitalist
notion in the west often that lurks at
the bottom of some of the metaphorical
Realms that we've been discussing that
there's something suspect about wealth
but the thing about wealth is that if
you use it ethically
it's life more abundant if you use that
ethically then part of the utility in
gathering wealth is that hypothetically
you can go well first of all make more
wealth with it but you can do good
things with it and so it isn't it isn't
like Scrooge McDuck luxury in the money
bin that we're talking about here it's
the opportunity to make things better
for people now the other thing we wrote
about not all bad you just talked about
the education front maybe we can close
with this next uh with this next
proposition and by the way for those of
you listening and watching this is just
one of many although Bjorn's done a very
good job of trying to rank order these
in terms of well let's do the cheap and
easy things first we might as well hit
the ball out of the park at least in the
places we can and maybe we can save some
of the problems we don't know how to
solve for the future which is perfectly
reasonable way of going about it you
also talked about we also talked about
the provision of of nutritional Aid to
to pregnant women and and women who have
infants and so do you want to just walk
through that briefly just very briefly
again uh we've gone from a world over
the last hundred years in 1928 we
estimate about two-thirds of the whole
world was deficient in food so basically
we were starving uh two-thirds of us
were starving today that number is down
below 10 but that's still very high
that's still about 800 million people so
there's still a big problem again we can
have diminishing problems to still want
to do something about how do you fix
this well in the long run you actually
need to get much better productivity in
agriculture and we have some other
solutions for that but it turns out just
giving out lots and lots of food is not
only very expensive because you actually
have to distribute it it also typically
destroys local agriculture you know if
you give out all the food then they
don't have any incentive to produce it
next year and you actually end up very
easily make more problems here is there
we have a few small a few really good
Solutions one of them is this and that's
the one for pregnant women so one of the
things with pregnant women is they
basically start off their next baby
right in their bodies and they typically
have very low levels of vitamins and
minerals and nutrients now again if we
gave them all the nutrients I'd probably
be better but that turns out to be
really hard but we can give them all the
nests
nutrients vitamins and a pill we already
do that in a simple sense because we
give them what's known as vitamin A and
uh
oh I'm sorry I'm just blanking that uh
uh um yeah some other thing that's sort
of in the standard package from World
Health Organization but if we expand
that the pill will be a little more
expensive but remember we already have
the whole infrastructure in place to
hand out this pill it's one pill every
day for every pregnant woman that's
about 50 million uh uh uh uh pregnant
women we're talking about every year so
it's not a small operation but it'll
actually be fantastically cheap because
we just need to exchange that pill it's
already been there uh being done there
we just need to get many more produced
and get them distributed and get some
more information out and if you do that
it means that the child will be born
with a better
possibility of developing its own mind
we know that because if you're not born
early or if you're not low birth weight
you have better chances in your life so
we can basically make about 50 million
kids better chances next year if we did
this it'll cost in the order of 140
million dollars so it's you know
literally peanuts that we're talking
about yeah if we did that these kids
would grow up it would basically mean
that somewhere between two and three
million more kids would be better at
school they would go longer they would
learn more they'd become more productive
they would help their countries become
richer again this is a simple thing
right very well well document a thing
and we know that if you spend one dollar
here you can do about 38 dollars of
social good and again this is not just
you know making up more uh value or
mixed Scrooge as you were talking about
this is actually making sure that it
really poor women can make the life for
the Next Generation much better the
point here is not the
daily matters has huge impact rather
than just go with oh my God the world is
terrible and then I'm just gonna give up
or I'm I'm just gonna go for these uh
cheap easy virtue signaling this is
about there are a lot of Technologies
there are a lot of Innovations where we
can actually make a lot of good at very
low cost very effectively isn't that
what we should be doing for 2023 okay so
let's sum let's sum up this conversation
I'll I'll sum it up briefly and then
let's see what you you have to add or
subtract from that so we started by
talking about
the underlying metaphysic or even
Theology of the current world view and
laid out the proposition that we tend to
see we tend to insist that young people
see the planet as a fragile virgin and
culture as a rapacious predator and the
individual as a parasitic predator and
that that has its echoes in the a Priory
religious landscape but that it's a very
one-sided story and the corrective to
that story is while nature can be pretty
damn hard on us and needs to be tamed
and controlled in in a manner that's
sustainable we should be extremely
grateful for what our culture has
provided us with not least the ability
to look at nature as though it was
benevolent and we shouldn't be so damn
hard on individual people because for
all their flaws they can be Norman
borlag for example or the people who
worked along with them who are genuinely
contributing not only to a much more
productive and generous economy but also
doing that in a manner that beneficial
on the environmental front and so we
need to balance our Viewpoint and we
need to stop terrifying young people
into apocalyptic Nightmares by insisting
that the world is going to collapse and
that all the power should be given to
like terrified centralized tyrants so
that's the first part
then we talked a little bit about
the motivational landscape for that
world view is that people are being
enticed into these apocalyptic views
partly by being offered an easy Pathway
to moral virtue when they're susceptible
to that need and so it's all about
climate it's all about carbon dioxide
there's only one problem if you're just
concerned about it that means you're
morally virtuous you've identified the
enemy and now you have nothing else to
do that's a bad model the proper model
is for people to
develop a sophisticated ethereum of the
world and of their own action that's as
sophisticated as the actual problem set
and to be willing to devote mature time
and energy to the solution of a set of
real problems which we could solve and
then we sort of closed the conversation
mostly you did that by delineating a
couple of the areas that are that are
basically constitute low-hanging fruit
we could educate
poor people for relatively
um low outlay economically certainly one
that would produce a tremendously High
return on investment we already know how
to do that the infrastructure is already
in place and we could do the same thing
on the nutritional front and then we'd
have fewer starving and stunted children
and they'd all be more well educated and
why wouldn't and they then we also
pointed out being wealthier and being
more intelligent they'd also be more
likely to take a long-term view of of
let's say ecosystem sustainability and
they'd start to work in a distributed
manner to serve the environment locally
and so like why the hell is that a bad
idea that seems to me like a really good
idea so I so anyways that's my summary
of the conversation do you have anything
that you want to add or subtract to that
I think it's a great summary uh I I
think it really just summarizes into
you've got to stop believing that this
is the end of the world that's not what
the data shows us and we've you know
talked about that for a number of
different things so we live much longer
we're much less less poor so there are
many fewer poor people air pollution for
instance indoor has gone down
dramatically we know how to solve many
of these problems and we are smart
species so we will keep on learning how
to fix this yes this is not about moral
virtue uh and and just showing up and
saying I want to do good this is about
the long hard grind of the Norman
borlags and all these other guys that
actually helped us think out what are
smart ideas that's what this third idea
was then or this third part of the
conversation was really about there are
a lot of smart things do you want to be
part of that all right for for all of us
uh to be part of that and I I think that
was part of why we also wrote this all
bet it's sort of uh you know the the new
year is a place when you start talking
about so you know what do you want to do
what what do you want to do for next
year how do you want to look at the
world stop being scared start thinking
about how can I help and wouldn't that
be amazing if we actually had a lot of
more people saying I want to help I want
to be one of the guys who helped get you
know these tablets out in a developing
country somewhere I want to be the the
gal who focuses on making sure that we
get these cheap tablets out uh to
pregnant women I want to help push
forward these very simple ideas and of
course come up with new ideas this is
the way we solve problems this is the
way we actually make the world even
better right well that was the other
stream that I didn't summarize is that
we'd also talked about the fact that the
mold in a Petri dish model biological
model of human existence is not
appropriate neither is the fox or rabbit
model is that we have the capacity to
generate and kill new ideas constantly
and we're very good at testing them in
those countries where there's freedom of
expression and freedom of thought we're
very good at testing those ideas we're
very good at implementing them we've
learned continually how to make more
with less we're getting better and
better at that in every part possible
way especially as our computational
power increases and so what that would
mean is that if we could shed maybe if
we could shed the apocalyptic pessimism
and encourage young people to work
diligently towards a mature and
integrated vision of the economy and the
environment invite them to participate
as people who whose basic Destiny is to
make the world a better place for people
and for nature itself that that's a much
that's a Viewpoint that's much better
that's much more likely to lift people
out of abject poverty and also to
produce a Greener and more sustainable
world
well said
all right
Dr lomberg hey for everybody who's
watching and listening I mean first of
all thank you for for participating in
this conversation and you know and and
more power to you by the way on the
upward and onward front there's no
reason to be
destroying your
your motivation by engaging in
apocalyptic Dooms saying when there's
many things that need to be done and
could be done that are productive and
useful and many things that are positive
that are beckoning and that have already
made themselves manifest but Bjorn noted
for example that we've lifted a
tremendous number of people out of
poverty in the last 15 years and we
could do an even better job at that in
the meantime
I'm going to talk to Dr Lombard for
another half an hour on the daily wire
plus platform I'm interested in with all
my guests who are generally very
successful and interesting people I'm
always interested in the matter in which
their
responsible Destiny made itself manifest
right so one of the things that all
young people contend with is the issue
of where to find the Central purpose the
meaning in their life and you know it's
easy to get nihilistic and cynical about
that and think that life has no purpose
in the final analysis but I think that's
a pretty gloomy and unwarranted uh
supposition and one of the things I have
seen among the people I've met whose
lives are together and who are doing
productive and generous things is they
do find engagement in something that's
truly meaningful and it does get them
out of bed in the morning and help
motivate them to be productive and and
not only for themselves and not only for
their own gain if in case that has to be
said but so that they're working in a
manner that's extremely socially
responsible and meaningful in a
reciprocal Manner and so I'm going to
talk to Bjorn about how his interests
made themselves manifest in the early
part of his life in my attempt to trace
how such things come about and so we'll
see you in January and Merry Christmas
to you by the way
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com